[Music]
it's been three weeks since Charo the
lab mix was put on antibiotics while
bets try to diagnose her persistent
cough since then an ultrasound has
revealed the situation is urgent so with
the ultrasound on Charl we did find what
looked to be a solid mass it didn't
appear to be like a twisted lung lobe or
an area of infection so we did aspirate
it and it came back as likely cancer
wasn't wasn't definitive but likely
without knowing for sure what the growth
is dr. Mike decides that surgery is the
best option but since the original
diagnosis was potentially cancer I would
hate for her to continue to suffer with
hard time breathing and coughing if it
were something different we figured we
either had a sink or swim dr. Mike will
perform a risky lung surgery on Charo
that he's never done before but it is
charas only chance at a good quality of
life for us it's a very uncommon
procedure it's the first one we've done
here since I've been here it'll probably
be pretty difficult he'll open up
tower's chest cavity and we move the
middle lung lobe before sending it to a
lab for diagnosis thoracotomy are
opening up their chest that surgery in
theory could be relatively simple on
paper and how the books describe it it's
very easy but when you go in there
there's always surprises
sponge
with such a challenging surgery ahead
dr. patty ayan Pietro will be on standby
in the operating room to assist dr. Mike
in case of an emergency
[Music]
alright we're about to go into the
internals okay so now once he opens that
chest the dog will no longer breathe on
our own so I want you to breathe 10
times per minute once dr. Mike gets past
the rib cage he will get his first look
at the growth in Charro's chest there's
the heart this might be a heart base
tumor if the tumor is growing out of
Charro's heart it will be almost
impossible to remove without killing her
hey Patti
feeling there dr. patty tell me what you
think about
it's gonna be really hard it's also
stuck to that other long wall yeah it
looks really bad I think we can do it at
this point I was either in the euthanize
er or what I didn't serve they would
have killed her but since somebody else
agreed that it would be difficult I was
like I have nothing to lose by
proceeding and so I just kept pushing
away at it to remove the growth dr. Mike
will have to maneuver around major veins
that carry blood to Charro's constantly
beating heart
we had to dissect away a lot we had to
remove part of the SAC around her heart
we had to dissect it away from some
major arteries and veins which was also
very scary
fortunately dr. Mike makes an
encouraging discovery so it's not
attached to the heart that's good news
the mass whatever it might be is kind of
it here it's a crown the heart so we're
trying to slowly dissect the way to find
out where we can actually remove it from
so it's just a slow process slowly scary
it's not a heart based tumor but dr.
mike has hours of complicated surgery
ahead to save chours life